hello people don't Walker here being a
child of the 80s and 90s you probably
know I grew up with a lot of TV and
movies and through that process of
destroying my brain with such visuals I
have seen a lot of great characters as a
lie you know I'm just a big character
guy even the story sucks in something
that has a really good character I'm all
over it I just love it so with that said
a lot of people keep asking uh you know
who are your favorite characters or your
all-time favorite character in any movie
or any TV show whatever uh and I was
thinking about I said you know what I
think I got a pretty good list for it I
think I'm actually gonna count down my
top ten favorite movie and/or TV
characters and I was thinking am I so
far than just doing like one video you
know what these are my favorite
characters these are just the characters
I can watch over and over I'm gonna give
them each their own video so all through
the month of April you're gonna see my
top ten favorite characters from TVs and
movies now keep in mind this is not like
the funniest characters or the best
villains or even the most influential
even though many of them are it's more
just my favorite characters that I can
watch over and over and over and never
get tired of the characters I wish there
was even more stories about them well
some of them are still stories going on
but they're the characters that just
bring so much to me and like I said I
can just never get tired of watching
their adventures so with that said these
are my top ten favorite movie and/or TV
characters
10 on the list anime fans unite it's
Edward from cowboy beep
as many of you know this is also one of
my favorite shows of all time and she
plays a major part she's sort of this
wild child that has more one side of her
brain working the side that understands
computers and technicals and so forth
while the other side is just her
childlike insanity always bouncing
always smiling always laughing she
doesn't know when to feel sad when to
feel confused where to live how she's
supposed to live what she's supposed to
be like she's just Edward and she's
anything she wants to be she'll say
whatever she wants to do whatever she
wants to be wherever she wants her
entrance into the show is just as quick
and spontaneous as her exit from the
show and both have a lot of comedy but
also sort of a bittersweet tragedy tour
you almost wonder what this kid would be
like if she did have the proper parents
or the right upbringing or I don't know
focus on anything why did she did we
wouldn't have our favorite EDD
hyperactive wild kid I think for me so
much of it just centers around the fact
that she's in her own little world I
mean she'll talk to people she knows
what reality is
she's even used her incredible
intelligence to adapt and survive all
this time but it seems like her
philosophy is life's a party might as
well have fun her missions and goals in
life seemed to change almost day-to-day
all she's clear about is that she wants
to have fun while doing it but that's
not to say she's not devoid of death
either in the episode where they finally
go into where she came from we find her
Paz is actually just a strange and
random as she is I won't spoil it for
you but it's incredibly fitting and also
leads to the perfect bittersweet exit of
our character I think another reason I
really appreciate her is because it
would have been so easy just to make the
computer nerd on this show your
traditional computer nerd big glasses
really unsocial awkward quiet your
typical geek but she's not she's just
her own category of crazy but like ibly
crazy and enjoying every second of it
and I know there's a fair amount of
people that say they can't stand this
character and to be honest I know
exactly where they're coming from she is
annoying she is loud she is a pain in
the neck she is unfocused at many times
she is uncaring and only wants to do
what's best for herself or whatever
distracts her attention but I guess for
me it never hit that point where it was
unlike
she put in her two cents she did help
out she had an unbelievable amount of
creativity to her and we just knew she
was enjoying whatever strange world she
was constantly in because I like people
that can live in the same environment
that many people would consider bad or
unaccommodating and instead can feed off
of all the good that it can give all the
cool stuff all the stuff that's worth
admiring all the stuff you can have fun
with all the stuff you can question all
the answers you can create just the
excitement of the mere possibilities
edward is definitely that for me and I
think that's definitely something to
admire she's crazy
wild and totally out of control and
loving every moment of it hence why
she's my number 10 favorite character